but anyway yeah we want to get into so
we're going to spoiler territory now all
right we're gonna go with some spoiler
territory right now I think you and I
had the exact same moment when it with
this film what we're like okay we get it
we definitely know what he's trying to
say and that there was a point where
where I was like I get it
yeah earlier on in the movie wouldn't
you know cuz hearing about how crazy
this is always sitting there going I
gotta pay attention to every yeah and so
early on I was like is this just one big
Bible metaphor yeah and I don't know
exactly where but yeah eventually I
think we definitely had the same I get
it yeah I understand
move yes I mean to kind of explain how
all we give you is like our
interpretation of what it all is about
really you know because at the end of
the movie after no-one's ever seen the
movie and there's gonna stick around
first for their part the end of the
movie ever they kill Jennifer Lawrence's
baby crowd of people inside the Laura
burns the entire home thank God and they
never wanted to watch somebody stab
people with glass cuz I kept thinking
there are biblical references in this
movie you know like cuz halfway through
the film when Jennifer Lawrence gets
pregnant and and then she eventually
when you know he writes his book he
writes his he writes the Bible that's
what Hobby rights or something yeah the
Word of God is what he's put down Javier
Bardem I was essentially good he's
essentially got cuz by the time Jennifer
Lawrence burns the whole place and she's
still breathing you know he says the
words I am and that's such a Christian
thing is I am you go through the Bible
anytime God's talking or Jesus is
talking and it says I am its capital i
capital a meaning like it's a prone at
the right word pronoun or I forgot
proper proper proper my dad yeah yeah
yeah its proper and so that's a very big
Christian reference it seems slight but
it really is an important factor if you
go in with the Bible in mind ya find all
kinds of
that's what I found fascinating about
the interpretation I was feeling with
this movie because a lot of time you're
watching I was watching this movie going
what the hell's going on in this movie
and by the time I got to that point I
was like everything makes sense yeah
which is interesting to see so much
debate about like oh does this movie
mean anything I'm like yeah clearly this
dude read the Bible ya know it's it's
the movie covers the entire Bible and I
feel like that ending makes it very
clear the beginning is you know Javier
Bardem and Jennifer Lawrence and like
you were saying how the cast of
characters man woman man is Ed Harris
and the first guy to show up he's at and
then his companion shows up moment like
a slave later and then their two sons
arrive who are having a squabble and one
kills the one kills the other like how
he killed Ellen he wants him with a know
like how the rock was when Cain killed
Abel exactly yeah and so that that
happens and then eventually when she's
pregnant she's like the mother Mary and
the second I was and there's like other
biblical references going on mother Mary
she's also kind of like earth you know
yeah I think it's my spellin mother yeah
mother Mary Mother Earth and you know
there's like stuff that's happening here
where it's like it seems like Javier
Bardem is consumed with fame and wanting
to please people and you see loves
people and then that but then by the
time it gets to the end you're like oh
Javier Bardem is Darren Aronofsky's on
personal point of view of who God is
this person who wants to serve people
and have people love him and worship him
and then when these people feel that for
him terrible things come out of humanity
pretty and he wants to steal and kill I
have an adhesive it gotta prove I was
here even the house turns into a war
zone at one point you know at one people
there's a one point where like a big
rave starts and it's like oh you know
yeah they're partying and then [ __ ]
the love all right now having sex and
graven image in the house becomes like
all seven deadly sins
and like in the matter of like 15
minutes so a into the movie and reality
starts to break and Bend and that's
really cool you know so when um you know
Jennifer once finally gives birth to the
baby and they all start bringing gifts I
look to my girlfriend's like oh the
babies Jesus I get it see I picked that
I picked that was the moment where I was
like okay like I was earlier on in the
movie I was like this has got to be
biblical and then yeah when they brought
gifts to the door I was like yeah yeah
yeah and they even wait days you know
they're in here the Bible this is the
neela stick view it at what an outside
view of biblical faith and what it does
to you yeah and that's probably the more
fascinating parts of me because a lot of
time you see films that do like Jesus
metaphors here and there which most of
the time in a movie it's like some
superhero is dying and he puts his arms
out so he's Jesus sacrificing himself
for the people and here it was more like
the Joseph and Mary and God water Bible
still run a Javier Bardem going I'm with
you but I'm not yeah yeah it's like god
I think we were saying on the car was
how like it's like his generosity point
of view of God being like I want people
to love me but I'm not gonna be there
for you when you need me yeah it's like
I'm not qualitatively here you're kind
of on your own in this chaotic man do
what you will and like people and you
know the fact that he who finishes his
book and then people start worshipping
him it is this is like the Catholic
interpretation I feel not not just a
Christian because Catholicism is very
specific enough it just came out that
you got all systems very specific about
Mary Mother Mary and I really feel that
Jennifer Lawrence's character is a very
big because in Krita and I feel like in
just regular Christianity it's not as
much worship about Mary it's like she's
an important figure but I think the
viewers a holy figure and in this movie
it's like yeah she is the holy figure of
the mother Mary and so so yeah the house
is all going crazy it's all serving it
is even one point even before the first
half when
goes down into the cellar and then a
frog comes leaping yeah those are kind
of things I'm not a big fan of when it's
like I got it and there are a lot of
very like fallow vaginal visual
references to things like rotting slits
and stuff and holes that keep appearing
that are either black or bloody yeah you
know there there's a lot of hint to just
being barren yeah and I also add just a
little nugget I believe that's Rachel
vices face it starts the movie off oh
really
yeah cuz I was like oh different face
because I was sitting there in the first
shot going is that Rachel vice and then
you know the movie starts and then you
have that Jennifer Lawrence moment where
she wakes have all messed up and bloody
in the single teardrop and I'm like Oh
something the earlier version of this
movie starred Rachel vices yeah and
Javier Bardem and the next version of
this movie stars whoever that actress of
the end is and Javier oh really I wasn't
Jennifer Lawrence who wakes her out of
the bed and goes baby really different
face oh I did not notice that I did not
notice that so I guess my question to
maybe you haven't asked because the one
thing I don't get is the prod oh it's
like the destruction this is a loop it's
a loo yeah it's the matrix Architects
the goddess logical conclusion then you
burn it down you start again yeah so and
that's what creates what is look what's
the biblical interpretation of that
though of like you know he pulls out the
love like okay yeah I get it like they
burned the whole house down it's she's
consumed in darkness the beginning there
was darkness and then he brings light
out of her bringing light into the world
but why the recreation process um that's
I don't know as well you know that cuz
because Christianity kind of teaches you
like what you do this one earth thing
and then you die and you go either to
the fiery pit or you go to the cloud
city yeah
so I I don't really know how that fits
into me at how the recreation school of
thought yeah but I just feel like yeah
this is just another one of his
creations because the thing is if you if
you think about the Bible if you think
about the book of Genesis why would God
just create one yeah cool
Oh put some power I have one earth we're
good
no I just feel like yeah there's only
life on this earth by the way yeah so
God becomes at least by this movie's
standard God becomes like a frustrated
artist who needs to get it out and
finally does and gets absorbed by
people's admiration yeah and meanwhile
he kind of leaves his rock to fend for
itself basically yeah I see that's the
fascinating part because I feel like
when I think of plot I get all the the
metaphors I get most of it at least
alright but I feel like if i rewatch it
I'd be like oh my even more details now
how it's linked and the way people
behave will also change cuz you know
like Javier Bardem for most of the movie
he's very like yeah it's very warm and
reassuring in a couple times he gets
very wrathful but even when he's not
being there or helping at all he still
has that kind of light aura about him he
seems kind of pixelated the whole movie
I mean some of its like super on the
like when they kill the baby oh yeah
they kill the baby they're eating the
baby eat in the body of Christ
yeah and then immediately ha beers like
we have to forgive them like you do
start to it is an interesting filter
through which to view faith and few God
because ya start to wonder about these
principles from a different direction is
the construct it's a dark direction for
sure
but it is interesting to think about it
is yeah it's a fascinating piece of
material and at least that's what the
interpretation we got from it yeah and
like I said if you if you're a creative
type of any kind I think there are
parallels you can easily draw and relate
to in this just because there is so much
like even the story of God and the earth
and everything is a story about a guy
creating something yeah and seeing how
that plays that I've heard many people
talk about how being a creative person
is the closest Connection we have to God
because God is a creator so when we
create it's the closest khatai we have
to God so I I get that yeah
it's a nice I don't I just don't think
it's is like it's no I don't think it's
just hard to interpret as people is
impenetrable as I was expecting yeah I
feel like the fountain is harder to
figure out than this movie yeah yeah
it's like if you know the touchstones
and you start to pick them up yeah I
think you'll understand it unless
there's a second deeper in that I don't
get yeah because there's stuff I mean
like there's stuff about where at first
I was interpreting his fame and all that
like oh the struggle with Fame and power
and wanting the people's approval to
love them and then I real hour about
like ones that loins the limit of
letting people into your personal life
too much and you're becoming a famous
artist but then eventually by the time
the movie ends you're like oh it's just
that's just god this Darren Aronofsky's
point of view of God and how he deals
with people
oh yeah I mean you can shrink that
example down and make it about pretty
much anything creative but also that's
part of the beautiful thing about this
movie yes it doesn't it's not only that
one thing it's just that surprisingly
the the key metaphor is pretty strong
and bold but also I was picking up hints
of like just ruminations on motherhood
and children because the thing is like
everyone in this movie except for
Jennifer Lawrence and kind of Javier
Bardem behaves like a child
everybody has no regard for anybody else
everybody does what they want and
assures everybody that it's fine yeah
and you know that made me start to think
about her like before she even becomes a
mother in this movie that started making
me think about that
about the handful and the emotional tax
that that is and that the couple scenes
where she's like I just want to be alone
with you mm-hmm
I just want to have a minute you know to
ourselves and and yet so there's there's
a lot to draw on yeah sure
well it's a fascinating movie highly
recommend you watching if you have seen
mother if you didn't watch it this
weekend or if you didn't watch it again
this weekend double feet you saw mother
which i think is a movie you'll talk way
more about than it I wouldn't I would
love to hear what you guys have to say
in the comment boxes like what do you
think about it what are your
interpretations on it do you agree what
will we interpret it as what deeper
meanings can you you know find there put
your comments down below this this is
that movie where you're like yeah
[ __ ] comment we gotta hear who our
people are thinking about this movie
because that's and hey kudos to Jerry
whether you even though like the big
consensus of this film is not like from
the general population it's not like
unanimously loved I love that people are
talking about it oh yeah and know a lot
of the time a divisive film is art yeah
it's like art I would rather a movie be
divisive than just fine yeah you know
and that's a big achievement right there
this is again this is a movie that I
don't know how I personally feel about
it but I think I commend Darren
Aronofsky and the crew that everybody
who put this together for doing a
bang-up job with the material sure for
sure yeah oh yeah oh yeah alright guys
well thanks for watching our review of
mother you can subscribe to the Rio
rejects you can click that notification
bell followed at John Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram and go check out
our patreon become a patron oject today
how come Oh be out sure the cameras
further away and it's pointing down
because of these little you know end
screen things they don't want to cover
our face we think about things now